today let me give you a few figures on
vaccine sharing
the european union is so far the biggest
donor of covet 19 vaccines in the world
our eu member states have shared more
than 350 million doses for donations to
countries around the world
the large majority
around 300 million doses
have been shared via covax
covax is now transferring them to low
and middle-income countries and we are
working hard with covax and vaccine
manufacturers but also with donors and
recipient countries to speed up the
actual delivery of these doses
in addition our eu member states have
delivered over 45 million doses
through bilateral donations
for instance to our neighbors in the
western balkans
so all together around 350 million doses
have been shared by team europe
but more is needed
at this point 44 of the world population
is vaccinated
a large part of the doses necessary for
these vaccinations were exported or
shared by europe
but we will do more
we will step up our effort to support
africa
where vaccination is lower than in other
parts of the world
our aim is to ensure that 70 of the
world's population is fully vaccinated
by the middle of next year
because we will only control this
pandemic
if we fight it in every corner of the
world